okay well trying go a little bit fast
cuz we lost a little bit of time there
this is what you got is what you got
we're at PI data la it is Thursday
December 5th 2019
I'm James Powell if you like this talk
you can follow me on twitter at don't
use this code so if you want to follow
me on twitter go ahead and do that many
of us here we're PI data attendees and
so we're very familiar with and we use
every day packages like numpy pandas and
network X and more specifically these
packages provide a lot of details and a
lot of additional algorithms and
mechanisms that we may use but most
specifically what we're probably using
within numpy is the ndra within pandas
the data frame with the network actually
using the diagram and as an aside one
question we might ask ourself is what
are these things really we might call
these things abstract data types or a
DTS for short but and when you think
about abstract data types in the context
of Python you might think oh python
gives us a bunch of built-in data types
like the tuple the list a dictionary the
set the frozen set we can describe these
in terms of being abstract data types
like the tuple is some kind of record
type the list is some kind of collection
type the dictionaries are mapping the
set is something akin to a mathematical
set and when we look at the number I and
D array the data frame and the digraph
we might say all the nd array is an N
dimensional array so it's kind of a
vector or a tensor or a matrix the
pandas dataframe is a columnar or panel
data data type the network x digraph is
something that looks like a tree or a
graph but when we think about a DTS
we're often thinking about these has
having very small api's for example if
we go back to the built-in types we
might think about a Python set as having
certain operations and certain cat and
certain characteristics for those
operations how performant they are what
the big oak complexity is for computing
these and so for a Python set you might
think about it in terms of the
intersection the Union the difference
the semantic difference a fairly small
set of operations or for something like
the Python dictionary you may think
about it in terms of just a number of
small operations whether an element is
contained in that setting an item
deleting an item by getting an item but
when you look at the ND array the data
frame or the network x diagraph you can
see the surface area of those is much
larger than what you might assume for an
ADT in fact what you might think is you
might think of these as being something
like a restricted computation domain and
so when we talk about research at
computation domains we end up seeing a
very common pattern we're writing Python
code
oftentimes you're writing Python code
and you look at some kind of entity some
business object some class and I'll make
this a little bit less abstract for you
so maybe some business object
that was a joke and you might have lots
of these and when you have lots of these
floating around your system you fart you
start to see serious performance
problems one of them and these are a
consequence of Python objects being too
big not being cache coherent and having
unbounded computational complexity and
you might address each of them of these
in turn you might say well Python
objects are too big and so what I can do
is I can and one of the reasons they're
too big is they carry this dict around
with them everywhere and so one of the
ways that I can address this is by
adding slots and this shrinks the size
of my individual Python objects so a
system that has millions upon millions
of Python objects will use less memory
but unfortunately that's just not very
interesting slots are not interesting
that's all I'll say about them you might
also look at this problem and say well
cache coherency is a problem you have
lots of Python objects floating around
in a system and the solution to this is
you could have a custom allocator
because nothing in the Python spec says
how things need to be allocated so you
can add your own little arenas and
custom allocate things to make sure
their cache coherence you can more or
less solve this problem the much bigger
problem is the unbounded computation
complexity of a Python object and this
is what necessitates the need for some
kind of restricted computational domain
in other words you might have some
Python object that has some add method
and you might create a Python list and
you might think of it like a vector even
though Python lists are not vectors
they're collections and you might
perform some operation like some on this
and it just works but if you think about
that object you can add unbounded
complexity to the internals that object
for example in this particular case each
one of these items has some hidden
dependency that won't be visible to the
actual container structure or to the sum
function and so when you do something
like this you start to break certain
assumptions that your container type is
going to have about how these operations
will be performed for example that they
are independent of each other that you
have some equational reasoning that sum
or addition should be associative or
commutative and this very simple type
breaks all of those assumptions and so
what you might say is that M PI and D
array is a very nice solution for this
because it gives us a solution to the
first two problems that you have
contiguous data they are unboxed data
it's machine types so you can specialize
the operations you do a summer and endi
array you're actually doing machine
level processor instructions for
computing that sum and most importantly
because these are machine types there
are no complex inter dependencies now if
int array gives you a computational
domain and what you have specific
restrictions where those restrictions
are things like we know the content of
this ND array are just plain integers
not some complex pipe
object that can have arbitrarily complex
behavior on it and so when you look at
the code that uses a panda's data frame
or an umpire in D array it often follows
a fairly simple pattern pattern looks
like this you do some work within pure
Python to load some data you may do some
work within pure Python in order to
clean that data and then you put that
into the computational domain you
perform a bunch of operations on it
within that computational domain within
that domain certain assumptions are held
because those assumptions are held
there's operations to be performed
optimally you can use for example
machine types and machine operations in
order perform operations within the
computer computational domain you can
say there aren't these hidden
interdependencies you can do things like
Auto paralyzed stuff and then at the
very end you need to pop it out of that
domain so you do something like a DF dot
plot inside that domain the data is
managed and so the domain can set
certain rules about what happens in
order for you to cross that boundary to
take the raw Python objects and put them
into the domain once they're inside the
domain they're fully managed by that
domain and so you can do whatever you
want to make that most efficient and you
can address every one of those three
problems what this suggests though is
that for every computational domain
there won't be a natural bound on the
surface area of the API in other words
for an ADT you'll have a fairly natural
bound on the surface area of that API
and ADT will only provide certain
methods that correspond to how you think
about that data type like pushing into a
stack and popping from a stack whereas
the research computational domain will
have to have an API that's large enough
to handle all the ways you poke that
domain to encourage it or to force it to
perform some computation so this API is
gonna be much larger and so it turns out
that that was not really an aside
because it's a very critical problem
when you need to do something that we're
gonna talk about in a moment it turns
out when you use a numpy ND array you
might use that numpy ID right directly
like this like you just create an array
with some numbers in it or you use our
panda's data frame you use that data
frame directly or you use a network X
digraph and use that digraph directly
however it is often the case that these
entities need to be situated in some
kind of production or business context
in other words let's say that you're
using a network X digraph but you're not
using a network X diagraph in order to
do abstract academic graph algorithm
exercises you're actually trying to do
something like perform point-to-point
OSN our computations for a mesh optical
network in that case you need to have
some representation between the
underlying data structure and the
entities that it's manipulating and you
certainly don't want to do this where
you say oh I'm going to figure out what
the
or between two transceivers and two
cities is and zero represents Los
Angeles and one represent San Francisco
you definitely don't to do this and you
definitely want to do something like oh
I'll make them strings instead
that's absolutely pointless instead what
you probably have is some custom object
and that custom object will have some
data that won't necessarily be used in
the computation and you put those into
your digraph now that custom data might
include information that's not using the
computation for example the coordinates
of the transceiver so you can plot it
nicely but it's not used as part of the
OS in our computation however there may
be computational elements in there for
example for that transceiver you might
need to take into account the baud rate
because you're doing some kind of power
sweep so you're trying to figure out
what's the optimal power for this
network in order to get the optimal OSN
are unfortunately it may turn out that
that information itself is mutable and
as an interesting aside one of the
things that we talk about when we talk
about Python dictionaries is well Python
dictionaries have keys and there's a
restriction on those keys they're unique
and also they have to be hashable what
we might know about network access
digraph is that it's modeled as
addictive dicta disks in other words if
you have a digraph that has two edges in
it you to V and V to W this is what it
looked like inside Network X and you can
see the notes themselves are the keys of
this dictionary which means the nodes
have to be hashable but if it turns out
that the nodes themselves are mutable
then how do you compute that hash and
we've seen this problem throughout you
know whenever your time puts them into a
set or a dictionary how do you actually
compute the hash in this case the only
meaningful thing you can do is to create
compute the hash on the ID if you look
at this and this doesn't shock you you
really need to take a closer look
computing the hash on the ID of the
object this is something that we're told
we should never ever do because we know
that we can't hash of immutable object
right we can hash an immutable logical
tuple
all day long but we try and hash the
immutable object we get this unhappily
error and we might have created a
correspondence in our mind that hash
ability implies immutability but there
is an important qualification there and
that qualification is hashed ability
implies immutability if you need random
access in other words if you're actually
manipulating these nodes in your graph
and you don't need to be able to pull
them out of the graph object out of that
computational domain
randomly but instead you're pulling them
out through mechanisms that you employ
on the unrestricted computation of main
for example the only way that we
interact with the nodes here is by doing
aji notes then we can loosen this
restriction for immutability for the
hash ability these underlying objects
and we can actually hash them off of
their ID and all
you have to then do is write some
function called find out by label that
will pull a note out of this thing by
its label and it'll just use G node so
it'll abide by the API provided by the
restricted computation domain in order
to interact with what's contained inside
of it and so we can actually bend this
little restriction that we've been told
from the beginning of when we learn
Python it was a necessary restriction
for creating an object a can be put into
a set or a dictionary however this is
actually not an aside because where do
you put that fine node by label function
it may be the case that you want to
create your own business object it
represents this mesh optical network and
so you might have some code that looks
like this you have a transceiver object
and amplifier a span you create a
network with the transceiver that's
connected to an amplifier connects to a
span which is a length of fiber-optic
cable connected to another end player
connected to another transceiver and you
put this into your own custom network
object that itself and gives you some
API similar to Network X digraph and so
you can see in this example at the very
bottom I do a dot add edge which is a
net which is a call a network X digraph
API and you need to put into that
network object somewhere this fine note
by label function or some add span
function so that might add in two
transceivers and automatically compute
what the span looks like and
automatically place amplifiers if the
span is two if the span might be too
long by itself and so you need to amend
that API need to supplement or add
additional things that API and how do
you actually go about doing that well it
turns out that we're told there's two
general ways to extend
types in Python or in any any language
whatsoever composition and inheritance
and we may be told that we should prefer
a composition this is what people tell
us all the time inheritance has too many
hairy corners prefer composition so
let's look at the compositional approach
we're trying to extend a network X
diagraph in the compositional approach
what we'd have is we'd have our own
custom class and inside of that we'd
have some attribute that actually would
have the network X digraph and so every
time that we need to provide some
functionality provided by that network X
digraph research a computational domain
we have to explicitly create a function
called add edge that then calls self G
at edge and you can think that this
becomes incredibly tedious especially
since as we saw in that first aside the
API of that researcher computation
computational domain can be quite large
and it turns out that we'll have to in
every case explicitly pull out of that
researcher computational domain the API
points where we need to interact with
what's going on there and so as an aside
there's a very important question we
to ask yourself which is who are we
really for example let's say that we are
the maintainer of a package called desk
and as maintainer to that package we
want to provide a desk data frame that
has a one-to-one correspondence between
the pandas not a frame in terms of their
api's and how would we actually go about
making that happen and if we looked at
the source code for desk itself we'd see
that desk has a data frame object and
inherits from an underscore frame type
that they give you and if you look at
that underscore frame you'll see that
inherits from some other mixin types but
there's no actual view of the pandas
data frame in this code at all in fact
if you look to this code the only place
you'll see it reference to a panda's
data frame is in a decorator called
derive from that seems to be mostly used
for the purposes of either testing or
documentation and so in order to
maintain that correspondence between the
desk out of frame and the panda's data
frame you have to go and make sure that
every API call that pandas has on the
data frame object is has its own
corresponding call in the desk
data frame object you can think that
might be a lot of work especially
considering that the pandas API is
neither published nor versioned which
means you have to constantly keep up
with API changes and pandas on their
data frame on your - data frame where
you're not you don't have any explicit
target contractual target for this is we
support up to such-and-such a version of
the pandas API because there doesn't
exist a publisher versioned api for the
pandas data frame now on the other hand
it's actually a little bit easier said
than done because for a package as large
as pandas it's got a certain maturity
and there's a certain limited amount of
churn people aren't constantly adding
methods depend it's not a frame so you
don't really have to play that much
catch-up but fundamentally every time
there's a change in pandas there has to
be some game of catch-up on the desk
side in order to catch up with that and
the compositional approach you can see
is going to suffer from this now it
turns out that in practice is not such a
hard problem at least not for desk
because the desk maintainer are
basically the pandas maintainers and so
they add something to pandas and they
add some in audacity at the same time
and it's not a real problem in fact as a
direct quote from Matt Rocklin yesterday
Dass considers itself to be tightly
integrated with the community and so
that's how they avoid that problem and
if you weren't tightly integrated with
community in that particular fashion you
were working on a project of your own
and you weren't also a pandas maintainer
you want to do something similar provide
a corresponding API in your path in your
project that could be interchange with a
panda's data frame you could solve this
problem with info you can write your own
tooling that says every time a pan is
released
now check for additional methods and
then give us a warning so we have you
know create a github issue that somebody
goes and implements it on our particular
corresponding object but that's gonna be
a lot of work and fundamentally we're
not coordinates oftentimes when we're
taking a packet who are extending it
we're extending it because we need to
add some marginal functionality but we
don't wanna have the entire cost of
maintaining this as one of the main
things we have to do we have probably
more to do they maintain an open-source
pack an open-source package we have to
solve real business problems and so any
of these approaches is just not
sufficient we will probably labor under
the assumption that there exists a
community of core devs who manage these
projects and so if we can externalize
this problem and make it somebody else's
problem then we can say good luck that's
your problem not mine but it turns out
this is also not really an aside because
what it tells us is that a compositional
mechanism for extending a type requires
a lot of maintenance you have to
constantly be tracking down the thing
that you're composing or the thing
you're composing against and make sure
that you're always mocking out or
snubbing out every single method that it
provides and so that leads us to maybe
looking at the other approach the
inheritance approach and you can think
that if the compositional approach is a
pol approach the inheritance approach is
a push approach in other words if you
have some derived type and it derives
from base type this code alone gives you
immediate access to the entire API
that's on that base type and then you
can programmatically surgically go in
and implement all of the overloaded
methods or overridden methods that you
need in order to add the core
functionality that you desire however it
is still the case that if there is no
contractual API it's possible in under
that on that base type somebody adds
some method that doesn't comport with
the things that you've already
overridden and they create a little hole
in that type and so for example you've
almost all seen this if you try to for
example subclass a Python dictionary and
you don't use collections not mutable
mapping you're probably seen this
because if you use Dyck dot update it
doesn't itself use that set item and so
you may have seen those problems when
you don't create a contractual API and
so it is necessary that in order for any
of this to work you need to have at
least something akin to a contractual
API where somebody has written out this
is the API this is what you have to
implement this is what you override
because in the absence of that this is
intractable and so an example of going
back to dictionary is for the Python
dictionary instead of inheriting from
dictionary you probably will just
inherit from collections are mutable
mapping which provides you that
contractually
PII and make sure that everything more
or less works what that suggests is the
inheritance approach will require some
maintenance and some of this maintenance
and the need for this contractual API is
unavoidable but there are some minor
problems with the inheritance approach
first when use the inheritance approach
you start to infect people's inheritance
hierarchies which can be very
problematic for large code base
especially if that large code base has
an existing inheritance hierarchy and
that inheritance hierarchy is using some
kind of naturalistic modeling as an
aside don't do not write your code
against some naturalistic hierarchy I
can't I don't have enough time to go
into why not but there's a talk that I
gave a couple of years back about the
pathetic fallacy and literature the
pathetic fallacy is this idea of Mis
attributed anthropomorphic qualities to
the inanimate for example writing your
source you're writing your code so it
kind of matches how you think about the
entities in the real world as opposed to
some limited mathematical domain where
you're trying to focus on modeling just
the aspects that you need in order to
perform a computation when you do that
you inevitably lead to problems
confusing the map in the territory and
the whole inheritance hierarchy the
whole thing falls apart so just don't do
that that however was an actual aside
but if you like that's interesting to
you maybe go see that talk now to take
it back to an example the example that
was using that talk where somebody was
trying to build a financial application
and so they create a naturalistic
hierarchy where they say a bond is a
type of a loan and alone is a type of
fixed income product and you can think
that if you need to then insert into
this the underlying numpy and da-rae
that this entire thing might be based
off or some pie tables object or some
computational domain where you are
actually performing the computations it
may be tricky to figure out where to put
it in this inheritance hierarchy so the
inheritance problem there's a minor
problem here there's a more immediate
problem which is inheritance often just
simply doesn't work especially with the
types that you're used to using directly
as part of your day-to-day work it is
possible for example to subclass a numpy
nd right this is possible and this
actually works you can subclass the ndra
you can put an object into it you can
perform computation when you perform
those computations you stay within that
type there's even some guidance there's
a piece of documentation if you ever try
to subclass in India right I would very
heavily suggest that you've read through
this entire page very carefully but how
to sub classes correctly because the
code that I just showed you here this
codes actually wrong if you do this this
is the result that you get which is
totally nonsense
and so even the simple example that you
just kind of that's interesting it kind
of works doesn't work now you may have
tried this already and you may have
tried this with the Python built-in type
like a float and the immediate problem
that you saw was it just doesn't work
you can't subclass a float in Python and
expect it to work because you can
subclass it you get the object out and
then the moment you perform some
computation there you fall out of that
type and so for example I create my own
custom float I put some restrictions on
it or I patch it or I override certain
behaviors in some fashion and then I
perform some operations like add it to
zero and the moment I add zero it decays
back into a base float and this is
because these types were not originally
written to be subclassed in any
meaningful fashion and it is possible
and if you look at something like the
pandas in data frame you'll see this
problem very directly in a pan it's not
afraid if you subclass that pan it's not
a frame and then try a very simple
operation like you try to merge it with
itself you'll immediately decay back to
a base data frame and you'll fall out of
your type which is not something that
you want because if you start chaining
operations after that first operation
you've immediately lost all of the
ability to hook into this type that you
and originally inherited from it in
order to accomplish now it turns out
that you can fix a little bit of this
with mechanism or infrastructure for
example in the case of the float this is
from a talk that I gave many many years
ago called generators will free your
mind where I create my own subclass of a
floating-point number in order to
customize how it gets printed as part of
the formatting protocol and you can
automatically discover all of the API
points we need to patch it out and patch
it out automatically using a class
decorator or in the original talk using
a meta class and it's possible it's kind
of a pain but still I think the
fundamental problem exists this will
work but I think it's still a fairly
surprising result when you look at these
two approaches and you see they have
fundamental limitations where the types
were not written to be an extended they
were not written to be composed wisely
they weren't written to be inherited
from and so it's quite surprising to me
that the types in Python are just not
designed for integration and most of the
data science types you deal with are not
like the nd array where it'll just work
but there's some caveats you have to
read through some documentation they're
more like the pandas dataframe where it
just simply will not work right off the
bat there's no way for you to easily
subclasses based off of how they are
written today now may be the case you go
into pandas and you could add a bunch of
pull requests and you can make it so
that a panas data frame could be
subclassed you might
resistance because how often people
really want to do this I don't know a
bunch of you might just be happy to deal
with the pandas dataframes but you can
think in a production context that might
be insufficient but how many people are
really using these in a large production
context it's another question you can
ask but fundamentally the types as they
are written today are not designed for
this kind of integration and in fact
most types in the data science ecosystem
are not designed for this kind of
integration you may think that there may
be one more choice besides composition
inheritance you might think that there
might be an object construction approach
by which you could find a way to make
this work and an example of what you
might think of when you try and think of
this object construction approaches you
might think of something that was added
in Python 3.7 the data class and you can
think the data class puts behavior on to
a type without inheriting or composing
it programmatically uses a class
decorator in order to add behavior to
the type once the type has been
constructed and you might think that you
might be able to extend this and so an
example is something that I've never
seen anybody do but might be a very
interesting area for research is to
create your own graph type and then use
decorators in order to create business
objects that represent that type like a
mesh optical network that has the
behavior of a network X digraph instead
of by inheriting or composing but by
using a class decorator then construct
to add those methods dynamically once
the type is constructed something that
looks like this I wonder how well it
would work because I don't think I've
ever seen anybody try this and so what
this leads us to is a very interesting
result that it's surprisingly difficult
to situate core types in the in the data
science ecosystem into a business
context I gave a talk a couple years
back called integration with different
Acula talked about a smaller set of this
problem it talked about research to
computation domains and it's
specifically numpy and how numpy poorly
integrated with the Python vernacular
and it goes into some details of where
this is actually a real problem I mean
you need to build something bigger than
just manipulations on an ende array you
need to have objects in your system that
are not just matrices or vectors but
something that have some additional
business meaning associated with them
and you just run into a bunch of brick
walls every single time you try it it
turns out we do fundamentally need
better mechanisms for integration in the
tools that we have but as an aside and
this is our final aside and an example I
want to show you something very
interesting that results from all of
these and this is truly an aside but
it's actually quite interesting we all
know that in Python you can write a get
adder on a type and this can hook
into what happens when you look up an
attribute on that type and so here if
you ask this type for some attribute
that doesn't exist it'll give you the
number ten and you know that if you
actually if that actually would already
exists this code no longer works because
get adder belongs to a protocol and so
instead of implement get add or you need
to implement get attribute but you know
that these did two whole points where
you can where you can hook into what
happens when you do type dot or instance
dot something and you know that there
are also protocol methods like Len that
you could implement in order for this
type to be able to respond to what its
length is but if you try and use get
attribute in order to implement length
this doesn't work this doesn't work you
can't tell get attribute oh when
somebody asked me for my Len method give
it this particular method but you also
know that there are other protocol
methods that are on that same data model
page which talks about how Len and
repper and hash work like get state and
get states used for things like pickling
and as an aside within an aside don't
use pickle I wish I could tell you why
not to use pickle but that's the end of
that aside don't use pickle now what's
surprising is this actually does work
and so certain parts the data model you
can patch out using get attribute in
certain parts you can't then you can't
patch up but get state for pickle you
can patch out and it works and the
question is why does that work well if
you look into the C Python source code
you can kind of figure out why it is
when you're doing a Len you end up
calling this PI object size and the
abstract implementation of Python
objects and inside of that you can see
on the third line here you have a action
on the fourth line here you can see it
does a M pointer dereference sq length
with actually pulls that function so it
does a direct pointer access or I think
going through they get attribute
protocol and this is why you can't
dynamically patch out some of these
underscore methods and if you look at
how get state works you might see that
for pi object there's a get state and
what it does is it actually does an
attribute lookup so it does fall to get
attribute get at our protocol and so
that's why that one works and so what
this should lead you to is a very
interesting dichotomy that nobody ever
really talks about that exists on all
Python objects that is to say Python
methods are split between methods that
have a tipi method backing things that
are actually implemented as part of the
underlying layout representation of the
type that are direct pointer accesses in
the c python source code and things that
actually go to the attribute protocol
and get state is an example of the
ladder and len is an example of the
former and if you're curious about what
that protocol looks like you can go into
the
include module and cpython object at age
you can see all of these methods and the
things that you'd expect add subtract
len repper hash and so on and you do
know that you could patch out an object
you could kind of override all of these
methods you could figure out what all
these methods are by looking through the
source code figure out which ones you
need to patch out patch them all
outright a lend a hash a rep or get a
tour again attribute and you can
completely mock out an object like this
now a question is why would you want to
do this well one interesting reason why
you might want to do this is you might
want to create a pure proxy may want to
create some object that proxies another
object in other words you might have
some object a and some object B and B
needs to pretend to be a either for some
debugging purposes or for some logging
purpose or in order to behave in order
to inject to surgically inject behavior
into a running system when it's 3 a.m.
in the morning and you tell yourself I
never thought I would be here writing
code that does this but I really want to
go back to bed so I'll do something
really crazy like this but you're
immediately stopped when you try and do
this using any of the mechanisms they
know about because an is instance check
won't work you can't tell a Python
object to pretend to be an instance in
other one you may know that you can on a
meta class of a type implement instance
check or instant check you can do
anything so here is a type that always
is that everything is always an instance
of but that doesn't quite work I mean
it'll work in this case but there's
actually a shortcut and so that very
first line when you ask is something an
instance of another instance if you're
an exact subclass instance that'll
bypass the instance check call so this
will work but this will fail here this
is a type that pretends not to be an
instance of anything else but actual
concrete instances of it will will no
longer obey this instance check protocol
and so there's some little holes in the
way that protocol works fundamentally
however because certain types that you
might want to proxy out or gonna be
closed types like int and you can't
implement instance check on the
metaclass of an inch you have no hook
point in order to do that unless you
swap out all the built-in types which
just won't work trust me I've tried this
it's gonna be more harder than you think
it is and it won't work this will just
give you a dead end so unfortunately you
can't proxy even very simple things like
instance checks and heaven forbid in
your code somebody actually tries
something exactly like this and there's
no way for you to proxy that because you
won't be able to proxy the type call you
might think you can because you might
think that you know when somebody looks
at a type that's really just a load
global operation and when somebody does
a dotted access that's just a load globe
and a load adder
do a function call that's loosely a low
global and a call function and you might
say a couple years back somebody added
in pep 5:23 this was worked on by a
couple of colleagues of mine Dino and
Brett to add frame evaluation api's to
Python so you can swap out the actual
frame evaluator in Python so I actually
a project that predates that that tried
something like this called our watch
where you kind of read watch is similar
to what you have in gdb to Python you
could actually say every time Python
looks at an object give a hook point so
you could swap out that object with
something else you have some interesting
results there but there were some
fundamental cliffs that you fall off
when you try this on anything serious
for example you do this by hooking into
the pushing of an object onto the Python
stack and so this will only work for
things that actually are evaluated
within the Python main evaluator which
isn't everything that might actually be
evaluated in a running program
especially one that has some scientific
computing use case for example if you
have some code like this and you cite
the nice it it'll turn into code like
this and you can if you can squint and
you can see on the third line of this
code they do a direct get at our string
so they don't go through the bytecode
and so they don't go through the vm
stack and so your hook point is no
longer there and you might think this is
kind of obscure because you know I could
just say don't use sight line for parts
that we need to hook out but the moment
somebody does something like number
dodge it and all that code gets swapped
out with LLVM I are you've lost your
hook point entirely because you escaped
the Python main evaluator and so this is
gonna happen this is gonna happen any
time the objects that you're trying to
proxy will go into a c extension module
and think if you had that c Sencha
module and it was only and all you had
it was in binary form and it wasn't even
obfuscated it's just a bra binary there
is no way that you're gonna be able to
patch that dynamically to figure out all
the additional hook points in that
you're not gonna be able to trawl that
assembly to figure out every time
somebody's looking at your object and do
something with it and so unfortunately
even the evaluator mechanism doesn't
work of all the mechanisms you might
think to employ to create a proxy the
evaluator mechanism the bytecode
mechanism the ast mechanism none of them
actually work they have these weird
cliffs where the moment you use number
or sight on or the data goes into a C
extension module you lose the ability to
hook into it and this is very surprising
there is no way to create a perfect
proxy in Python and it's a surprising
result because it turns out in Python we
have an object you kind of got what you
got you got that object and you can kind
of mock out certain pieces here and
there but you can't mock out the entire
what you think you would be able to
because Python has such a rich runtime
it has the ability to mock out so many
different things to stub out or to
implement all of these behaviors and
this is what makes Python so dynamic but
what you might see is that Python is not
really fundamentally dynamic it's more
operationally dynamic in other words
what you can think is that the Python
designers create a specific interface
for Python they created hook points at
that specific interface like LAN and
hash and instance check and you know
import hooks and whatnot and there's
just missing parts of that interface
like is instance or type or that compare
is where you just can't hook into them
and because it was operationally dynamic
and there's those missing hook points
you lose this ability to automatically
dynamically extend behavior of an
underlying type to for example at the
far extreme create a pure proxy and
unfortunately no amount of interpreter
patching can solve this you might think
you could do that you might think you
could use interpreter patching to patch
out is instance because you could say
well there's a PI object is instance and
it's a symbol I can find so I can go
when I can find that symbol and hook it
out and you can do that and it'll kind
of work but the problem is that
somebody's gonna do this and in the pure
proxy case this should probably work you
should be able to be indistinguishable
from the underlying type but you can't
mock out the is check like you can mock
out the double equals check you might
think that you can cuz you'll go into
the see eval and you'll see that there's
a compare a compare outcome function
that actually does this check and this
is where the exact pointer this is where
the pointer quality is done the appoint
equality check is done you could say I
could swap this out even though it's a
static symbol I can kind of go up the
stack to where the evaluator is use pet
523 to swap out the evaluator so when
somebody does X is y I can hook into
what that is but that won't work because
you'll end up having to try to proxy out
some like a nun pi n D array and if you
draw through the numpy and D array code
you'll find code that looks like this
this is for assigning arrays for doing
copies there's a bunch of code here
where they try to eliminate redundant
copies by looking into that C type
itself and what you can think is because
the numpy end array is fundamentally or
strictly computation domain and the
guidance of the restricted computation
domain is that inside that domain the
type has full control over the data that
it contains such that it can perform
optimally performant computations on
that data it is free to be able to poke
at the underlying information on that on
whatever fashion it wants like non ABI
compatible macros or
even in line functions and so there's no
way you're gonna be able to catch all
those points and stuff those out and so
unfortunately it turns out there is
really no perfect mechanism for proxy
and Python we do need better mechanisms
for proxying that was really an aside
and so to conclude to wrap up I really
want to ask I want you to all ask what
does this all mean well we do need
better mechanism for integration in
Python if we want to situate a data type
that happens to be one of the core
scientific computing data types that we
use we don't really have easy ways to
situate them in a business context by
extending them composition and
inheritance both have serious problems
nobody's really tried the obviou
construction approach if we want to take
this to an extreme and do something with
proxying there are severe limits on how
well we can proxy things because we have
all these weird edges that require
in-depth knowledge of how the Python
evaluator works or how the Python
ecosystem of execution works and so I
want to leave you with one final
question which is what did this example
really have to do with the rest of the
talk what was this talk even about I
don't know you got what you got thank
you so much great talk so if everything
has weird clips what is the weird cliff
with the descriptor API and integrating
that way oh there's a really major one
super doesn't work
so everyone says oh use super right and
that's how you actually call back up to
the drive class why had an example once
where I had an API that was mocking out
a Windows API for GUI purposes and they
were and so you'd have methane is like
dot font and it would be this would be a
descriptor it'd be a property that you
would set and then behind the scenes
we'd do some mechanism to match it up to
some Windows GUI API well if you need to
subclass that in order for example fix a
font at a certain thing just to patch
out some application because it's 3 a.m.
and you just need to patch it out to get
it to work so you can go to bed super
it's properly respects get on the
district 2 API but it does not properly
respect set and so you have to be able
to look through the descriptor to
understand that you no longer have this
ability to be ignorant to whether
something is a property or an attribute
you have to actually look through the
descriptor to figure out oh this is this
a property or not because super will not
give you the behavior that you want and
so there are these weird corner cases
now the response from a core developer
would be did you really need to do that
in the first place and yes if you need
to use the need to employ the full gamut
of pythons dynamic behavior to save
yourself a lot of time because you're
just one person doing one task you have
more things to do than to track down all
these little corner cases yes you do but
the other answer would be well I don't
know just hire an intern or something so
is the answer to use a different
programming language no because I think
the answer is maybe maybe the interest
is if you're if you're an analyst and
you're just using like paint as data
frames and numpy and D arrays directly
you're using these core types directly
you're happiest can be you don't really
need anything fancier than um that I
doubt afraid and you may be happy to
manipulate that data frame directly but
if you're a data engineer and you need
to situate that into a business process
that may be and if that's something that
happens to be done more and more
commonly as I suspect it is then maybe
we need to go back to some of these core
types and think about their
extensibility and figure out better ways
to extend that actually the answer is
switched back to Python to just abandon
Python 3 that's the answer that's the
official answer YouTube's switch back to
Python to Python 3 is done for how about
that actually surprisingly enough some
of the stuff works very differently in
Python 2 with old-style classes for
example old-style classes they dispatch
off of the data model method on the
instance not on the type and so some of
this stuff some of this dynamic patching
might actually work a little bit better
there if I remember correctly and so
let's bring python 2 back any other
questions okay thank you so much
[Applause]
you